Florida Governor DeSantis alleged last
week that a Fed made digital U.S dollar
would let government block transactions
like buying a rifle or filling up with
too much gas
he added speaking at a Pennsylvania
conference on Saturday they're going to
try to impose an ESG gender referring to
the private sector policy amid aimed at
the advancing environmental and social
and governance principles which
conservative lawmakers across the
country have been pushing to curb it is
seeding the power of our Financial
Freedom to Central to a central bank
which does not have our interest at
heart the Republican governor who has
been widely floated as a potential
primary rival to president Trump has
introduced legislation of Florida
seeking to ban the use of any fet issue
digital currency in the state and has
called on other states to do the same
the FED is re-u dying its fed now
initiative which aims to shorten the
time it takes for banks to send funds to
other banks for a planned July rollout
separately it has also been exploring
the possibility of issuing a digital
version of the dollar that households
could readily use instead of cash the
central bank issue currency would be
using digital wallets offered by the
private sector including by consumer
leaders now Powell
said we haven't decided that this is
something that the financial system in
the country would want or need so that's
going to be very important that's what
Powell said okay and then the Santa's
comments came with endings of remarks of
anti-vaccine were activist Robert uh F
Kennedy they have to put it that way who
tweeted Wednesday that a Fed issued
currency would allow the government to
surveil all our Private Affairs
financial affairs enforce dollar limits
on our transactions restricting where
you can send money freeze your assets or
limit your spending or approve to
approved vendors if you fail to comply
we're arbitrary uh uh vaccine uh
mandates like it's another one at that
time when you see this what do you think
about this well I think about the danger
it poses to the nation's strippers
because
because that's where I saw Tom going if
it's if it's digital and it's on your
phone some guy is going to go in to a
strip club and I'm going to make it rain
in here and he's gonna be throwing his
phone and she could get hurt
no this what I think here I think
there's some truth to it that if the the
issue is it's not just a digital dollar
it's all the tracking now on one hand
they say well now then people can't
cheat on taxes and this and this and
this and I I think that there's you know
the whole concept the first of all what
they're talking about up above in that
digital systems that are all you know
aligned we have to take a look and step
back and look at convenience
for instance does anybody remember when
you had to look at the back of your ATM
card maybe when you're 18 years old and
the symbol had to be at an ATM that was
on the back of your card you remember
that oh is this your 7-Eleven plus
system oh I'm plus system with my Wells
Fargo card I can get money here well now
it's completely ubiquitous you can go to
any ATM and get money with your card
that's how the banking system got it
together so it made it convenient for
people to go get money wherever they
want to get money so part of this is
we're going to make it easy for the
banks to work with each other and
instantly transfer overnight that's not
a bad thing pay your car loan because
it'll be with a bank pay your credit
card it's with a bank that part is good
and then the um the ATM part of that
that just described which is true
history that is a good helpful thing
moving it Forward what people are
worried about is if the government
through a digital currency also has the
ability to digitally track everything
and when you see what happened to you
may not like it but you see what
happened to Andrew Tate who had his
stripe turned off because stripe was
told turn him off wow and they turned
him off as part of a canceling effort
the danger is you can have canceling
efforts which has never happened except
for stripe Facebook Twitter Instagram
people getting canceled everywhere you
can't have a canceling effect out there
that part makes me very worried and this
happened this this we heard this story
yesterday isn't it just random that the
cash app guy gets stabbed to death and
dies in San Francisco
we see the films and everything yeah
it's very weird though isn't it like
it's not deep like that horrible tragedy
100 and I don't hope to see one thing or
another but it appears to be a random
mugging killing and I hope it's not
something deep like me neither but it's
this Ranch just to be clear we were
talking about Central Bank digital
currencies right cbdc's and I think that
the biggest concern that people have
with this is more government control
goal and now it's control not over your
life just now they're controlling your
money it's over and whether it's like
your taxes whether you didn't pay a
parking ticket they can freeze your
assets oh you didn't get vaccinated well
so we're gonna we're gonna take your uh
your wages garnish your wages
we're gonna turn you off so we were
talking yesterday about the Patriot Act
and government surveillance and now this
new thing that just been rolled out less
than a month ago that Charlie Kirk was
talking about the restrict act it's and
we're also seeing what's happening with
the biggest concern with the banking
right now is the nationalization of
banks it's like oh no banks are certain
Banks Can't Fail now too big to fail
this nationalization of money now with
the Central Bank digital currencies I
think is a way bigger concern than
people understand this is not Bitcoin
this is not you know
just hey you know your money can't be
tracked there's it's decentralized
currency no this is centralized currency
Big Brother this is Big Brother coin
exactly so I think this is a big concern
my fear is that they're gonna Market it
in a way that it's like it's gonna make
life easier pay your taxes online do
everything online this is some big
brother this is what happens in
China because in China don't they have
something called the social credit score
yes isn't that something I don't know if
Rob you can pull that up oh you said
something about she uh you got the jam
now like you you you don't do anything
that the government doesn't want you to
do it's jail time so here China
exactly the third trial this is this is
Russia can you read that out yeah so
China's social social credit system
gives individuals businesses and
government entities a credit score based
on their
trustworthiness a bad credit score will
have penalties like reduced access to
credit and fewer fewer business
opportunities
The Establishment The Establishment in
America loves seeing how China has such
control over its people that's their
hero to see hey how can we have more
control over our people so none of them
can come and push back with what we have
to say and what our agenda is anyways
it's obviously a uh idea that a lot of
people are concerned about and it makes
sense why you ought to be concerned
about something like this let free
market do it because you can always have
a choice to go somewhere somewhere else
if they do it they can control you in
ways free market cannot so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]